you guys were kid actors
i was a kid actor and now we're parents
what do you say to the kids what's your
guidance what's your
like wisdom and how do you handle it i
told them
uh when i first met them at the table
read of course we saw their auditions
but i told them remember that you
were made perfect and this was the thing
before you were born all right so before
you were born
you are already perfect this is not the
thing that's going to make you perfect
this is not the thing that's going to
change you this is part of a long
journey and what do you tell your kids
though
if they wanted to get into acting well i
have a very
strong line of communication with them
about it
and that is that i don't want them on
social media
or i don't show them because look i have
all sorts of
wonderful baggage that i would never let
go of or have it
any other way because i wouldn't be
exactly who i am
at this moment in time without all those
experiences and i'm always trying to
kind of keep them
just grounded and not feeling privileged
and
um as sort of figuring out
what is important and appropriate and i
just say to them
do school stuff do school plays be in
the arts and then sometime around i
don't know
14 to 16 you will know who you are as a
person
and whatever that is that you choose i
will support it
i would be the first person to help them
but like
maybe not before 14 15. what age did you
start
11 months
when did you guys get your start at
exactly what age
ooh uh i started out
in a theater when i was about
i want to say a 12th like 12 years old
you know because i was doing everything
in the classroom and i was a bit of a
class clown
and my parents were like okay we have to
find something and they put me into a
community theater
and then i was like oh this is it this
is what i was
looking for like keenan i know you guys
started very young younger than
me on the news right i mean it was only
doing like school and church
type stuff but i do remember like
community theater really being like a
turning point where i noticed that this
was like a real profession
did you guys have the head sheet where
you have to like have
three different expressions so you can
sell like i'm serious
i'm crazy and i'm something else grab
bag
that was for the commercial kids but we
could only afford like one picture at a
time
so it was just one good pose with a
sweater
just a nice young man
you